Was ist los in der 2. Liga der Männer? Diese Frage wollen wir jetzt beantworten und wir legen ein Fokus auf den HSV und Schalke 04 mit Torsten Wieland von 1000Freunde.de und Thomas Hürner von der SZ. Nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Und das 1 zu 0.
Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl. Es ist Zeit, endlich mal wieder über die 2. Liga der Männer zu sprechen. Warum es diese Sendung erst jetzt gibt, alle diejenigen, die die letzten Wochen im Rasenfunk verfolgt haben, das lag am Tod von Kai Bernstein. Es hat sich nicht so ganz richtig angefühlt, nach diesem einschneidenden Erlebnis ganz normal mit dem Sportlichen weiterzumachen und das irgendwie kurz in einem härteren Segment abzuhandeln. Deswegen ist ein langes Tribüngespräch erschienen am letzten Montag, an diesem Montag sogar zum Tod von Kai Bernstein. Wir arbeiten ausführlich auf, wer er eigentlich war und für was er stand und was mit ihm dem deutschen Fußball verloren gegangen ist. Das haben schon sehr viele von euch da draußen gehört. Ganz herzlichen Dank für das überwältigende Feedback. Selten eine so positive Rückmeldungswelle bekommen. Also das könnt ihr sehr gerne hören im Tribüngespräch-Feed. Und damit aber habe ich auch wieder ein besseres Gefühl damit, jetzt dann in die sportliche Betrachtung dieser Rückrunde zu gehen, weil wir dem Ganzen eine eigene Sendung gewidmet haben. Und das wollen wir jetzt tun. Wir wollen gucken auf die ersten drei Rückrundenspiele. Thomas, du bist hier von der SZ. Ich freue mich total, dass du dein Debüt gibst im Rasenfunk. Was war denn für dich die größte Überraschung dieser bisherigen drei Spiele?
Aber das heißt, das, was Thomas ja eingangs erzählt hatte mit der übergestellten Fußball-Idee, also für sowas hat man wirklich dann jetzt gerade keine Zeit.
Ja, diese übergestellte Fußball-Idee ist ja auch immer so eine große Nummer. Ich glaube, das ist auch oft viel Mythos, oder? Also ich glaube, dass sowas mit dem Trainer halt kommt. Also so eine Fußball-Idee, dass ein Club sich die gibt, das gibt es halt in Teilen. Aber auch Werder Bremen hat natürlich, als damals da Thomas Schaaf rausgeschmissen wurde, erst mal drei oder vier andere Trainer geholt, die dann plötzlich mit einer ganz anderen Philosophie aufgetreten sind. Also das steht und fällt damit halt. Also der Fußball von Union Berlin wurde von Urs Fischer geprägt. Und wenn Urs Fischer da nicht aufgeschlagen wäre, hätte Union Berlin vielleicht einen ganz anderen Fußball gespielt. Das ist ja nicht so, dass das von vornherein auf dem Reißbrett festgemacht wurde. Und dann hat man sich den Trainer ausgesucht. So ganz so ist das dann halt doch nicht. Auch wenn viele Fans das, glaube ich, immer glauben und sich das irgendwie wünschen würden. Diese große Idee hat irgendwann mal einer gesagt, hat bei Ajax oder bei Barca die F-Jugend schon genauso spielt, wie die erste Mannschaft. Und seitdem sagen alle Fans, das muss bei Schalke nur viel genauso sein. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht realistisch. Das ist schon so, dass der Trainer natürlich derjenige ist, der ein Spielkonzept dann irgendwie entwickelt. Natürlich mit dem Sportdirektor. Natürlich sollte man sich überlegen, wen holt man sich, wofür steht der Trainer? Und dann da eine Linie reinbringen. Das ist der große Punkt, der bei Schalke nur viel dann auch häufiger mal nicht funktioniert hat. Weil man hat dann irgendwie – ich gehe jetzt nochmal in die Vergangenheit, aber das plastische Beispiel ist – Ralf Rangnick hat man verpflichtet. Der tritt zurück, weil er gesundheitliche Probleme hat. Und als nächsten Trainer holt man Huub Stevens, der irgendwie am anderen Ende der Fußballwelt von seiner Idee von Fußball anzusiedeln ist. Und solche Sachen haben sich halt immer wiederholt. Also es gab jetzt halt nicht unbedingt die Linie da drin bei den vielen Trainern, die Schalke geholt hat, dass man gesagt hätte, die stehen für dieselbe Art von Fußball. Das sollte man schon tun. Aber natürlich muss man das jetzt entwickeln. Und das entwickelt halt ein Trainer halt mit so. Und da ist jetzt Karel Gerrard derjenige, auf den ich da meine Hoffnung setze. Auch wenn es irgendwie plump klingt. Wer sonst? Das ist halt immer der nächste Trainer, der gerade kommt. Und das ist jetzt halt derjenige, welcher eben.
Ja gut, klar. Der aktuelle Trainer ist immer der, der am nächsten am Herzen ist. Aber wie groß würdest du denn die Kurve in der Linie von Thomas Reis zu ihm beschreiben? Jetzt, nachdem man jetzt ja schon ein paar Spiele gesehen hat. Vorher ist das ja immer so eine theoretische Diskussion.
Also ich glaube schon, dass der Ansatz ein anderer ist. Also mit Thomas Reis wurde halt schon – ich habe ja vorhin gefragt, wie das ist, wenn man Trainer hat, der hauptsächlich nach vorne denkt. Unter Thomas Reis war halt viel gegen den Ball. Da war echt viel gegen den Ball. Und was dann mit dem Ball passiert, wenn der Ball mal da ist, das ist nicht so richtig ausgearbeitet worden. Und Karel Gerrard ist da schon ein bisschen anders orientiert. Ich glaube, der denkt mehr mit dem Ball. Schalke hat halt gerade Probleme in der Defensive. Jetzt kann man wieder sagen, okay, dem fehlt jetzt auch die Balance. Das muss man nochmal abwarten. Die Spiele unter Karel Gerrard waren halt sehr unterschiedlich. Es gab Spiele dabei, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt konnte man schon erkennen, das soll in die richtige Richtung gehen. Und dann gab es wieder solche Rückschläge. Das Spiel gegen den HSV war aus Schalkersicht eigentlich ganz okay. Das ist halt verloren worden. Und dann hat man aber am Ende noch gesagt, okay, das war jetzt der HSV. Die sind irgendwie besser als irgendwie alle anderen. Da konnte man jetzt irgendwie so einen Haken dran machen. Das konnte man für sich verbuchen. Aber wenn man dann natürlich gegen Casas Lautern so eine Leistung hinterher schiebt, wo dann irgendwie erstmal gar nichts stimmt und wo man dann so auseinandergedröselt wird, ja, das ist dann natürlich eine Katastrophe. Und sowas wechselte sich in der Zeit mit Carre de Ferraz jetzt eben auch ab. Die letzten Spiele so gegen Führer und davor, das war ja völlig okay. Davor ist man eben von Düsseldorf auseinandergespielt worden. Und da ist halt noch keine so richtige Linie drin. Man hat sich dann halt erhofft, dass das natürlich im Wintertrainingslager zustande kommt, dass da die Linie reinkommt. Umso krasser war dann eben, dass dieses Kaiserslautern-Spieler eben so reingerauscht hat, wie ich gerade sagte. Also das HSV-Spiel konnte man sich dann noch irgendwie erklären oder hat man sich dann noch, ich sag mal, schön geredet.
Heieiei. Also HSV und Schalke, das sind echt so zwei riesige Themen. Das ist unglaublich, über wie viele Aspekte man da sprechen könnte. Ich habe eine abschließende Frage an euch beide. Das ist eine Transferfrage. Ich nehme ja hier aus Bayern heraus auf, da ist immer die letzte Frage in der Schulaufgabe, ist eine Transferfrage, die entscheidet zwischen 1 und 2. So ist das hier. Sogar schon in der Grundschule. Das ist ein ganz fantastisches System. Welche Eigenschaft, Torsten, vom HSV, würdest du dir für Schalke 04 wünschen?
Das variable Offensivspiel würde ich mir wünschen. Das, was Tim Walter eben vorne sehr kreativ hinbekommt, es schafft, da die Innenverteidigung der Liga auseinanderzuspielen, das würde ich mir halt für mein Club wünschen.
Und dann 3 zu 4 gegen Karlsruhe verlieren am 27. Spieltag zu Hause. Aber okay, ich verstehe deinen Punkt. Thomas, was würdest du dir von Schalke 04 für den HSV wünschen?
Das setzt jetzt so ein bisschen voraus, dass ich HSV-Fan wäre. Jetzt bin ich in dem Sinne vielleicht nicht. Aber was dem HSV, glaube ich, gut täte, wäre der Mut, auch schwierige und unangenehme Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und das ist, finde ich, in den vergangenen 2, 3 Jahren nicht so häufig passiert.
Sehr interessante Antwort. Ihr zwei, das war sehr interessant. Es hätte noch ewig weitergehen können. Ich habe irgendwann auf die Uhr geguckt und bin ein bisschen erschrocken. Da habe ich euch ein paar Minuten früher eigentlich versprochen, dass wir aufhören. Umso mehr danke ich euch beiden, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Ich werde natürlich verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Torsten Wieland, Friend of the Show, seit der ersten Folge. Haben wir ja mal rausgearbeitet, Torsten. Danke, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Und herzlichen Dank sensationell. Schön, dass du mal hier mit dabei warst. Danke, dass du dich gemeldet hast, Thomas Hürner. Sehr gerne sprechen wir noch ganz, ganz häufig über den HSV, vielleicht auch mal über Inter. Schön, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Bis demnächst.
Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk. Alles, was wir hier machen, ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei und wird getragen von Menschen wie Mark Briele, Saure Hefe 1887 – ist kein Zufall, dass du hier erwähnt wirst – Tobias Bönke, Rudi Thorben und Michael Rolando. Sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur finanziell, sondern haben sich auch als Supporterinnen und Supporter registriert. Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf rasenfunk.de da findet ihr all die Sendungen, die wir machen. Es ist wirklich eine ganze Reihe erschienen. Also zum Abschied von Jürgen Klopp haben wir eine Sendung veröffentlicht. Kai Bernstein habe ich schon erwählt. Natürlich dann Männer-Bundesliga, 1. Liga, die Frauen-1. Liga haben wir auch eine Sendung veröffentlicht. Und zum Afrika Cup haben wir auch neulich eine Sendung aufgenommen. Und da wird auch nächste Woche wieder was kommen. Also rasenfunk.de, da findet ihr Beschäftigung. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund. Bis bald. Macht's gut. Ciao. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Danke. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.